starting up science is the topic under
which yale university professor and this
year's heinrich vlan price laureate
craig m cruz and other scientists from
germany
will remotely come together and discuss
craig m cruz will share his first-hand
information on how scientific research
transforms
into real-world medical treatment
yeah so my lab works with the interface
of chemistry and biology
and we're using chemical approaches to
answer biological questions
and so this really leads us into many
different areas but the
the research that i'm going to be
awarded on
is one that is an application of a
technology that my lab
has developed to hopefully drug new
proteins that haven't been drugged
before the chemist and professor at yale
university
is a pioneer in his field and now
honored for pioneering targeted protein
degradation
as a new therapeutic principle in
pharmacology
the idea is as simple as fascinating
each cell has a natural control system
that regulates the lifespan of a certain
protein
usually pharmaceuticals simply stop the
function of a problem causing protein
but mr cruz and his team
managed to get those proteins to fully
degrade hence
protein degradation
so the biggest question is knowing which
proteins are going to be the most
impactful
right with over 20 000 different
proteins we
don't have the resources or the time to
drug every single one although in theory
we could and so
we need to work closely with doctors
with geneticists with biologists
who will tell us which are the most
important ones that if we could control
their function we hopefully would have a
clinical benefit
so the protein degradation approach
could have the potential to
fundamentally change the way drugs are
developed
and work in the human body what i would
like
to happen is that that drug companies
would use the technology that my lab
is developing to go after new drugs that
would have greater impact for
for patients that currently are
suffering and don't have the options
that they need
you